Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Cozy!
I am trapped alone in this car...
With an air freshener.
This hardly feels necessary in a forest - well I dunno exactly don't know where I am.
I just need to make sure my uncle's okay. Then I can leave.
So it's a point and click style adventure...
But it's a horror game.
So don't be fooled by what you see in front of you and the relaxing calm music.
I'm sure that eventul-
Oooh...
That eventually hell will unleash itself
Soon.
So we need to go!
Oh.
The wind is bitter and cold.
So we need to go all the way to my uncles house
And we've made our way here
And the lights are out...
ohH LOOK.
Key under the rock
How about I use that on the doooor?
*markiclick*
Alright, suprising... huh.
OH...
Well that's...
That's not exactly a lovely piece of painting...
It looks like someone falling down the stairs and blood coming out of their mouth.
And generally disarray...
Well this is a daaaa-
*Markiplier stays silent while remaining a spooked face.
Oh...
*click x3*
Oh... okay?
Alright then I don't know why that was there...
Why is there an tiny alcove at the bottom of th-...
Alrighty then.
*markiplier inhales.*
Heeeey...?
Hi... why is there so much wind whistling through this hallway?
Why is this neccesary? ;~;
Oh hello?
Can I get myself a glass of water?
Ok... So I gotta find my uncle.
So somehow
*MARKILAUGH*
I've... uh... no idea how I'm going to find my uncle.
Maybe in this dark alcove?
*sarcastic* Oh good.
Old moldy pillow, nothing else.
Rather damp, I'd not know with what.
*markicringe*
Gross.
*INHALES*
HI.
OH
HO.
HI...?
HOOOO.
HI.
HOOOOOOO.
HI...
HE'S DEAD
*scared* OHHHKAY!
ALLLLRIGHT.
Oh boy.
I should get help.
YEAH. NO JOKE I SHOULD GET HELP.
I should get the heck out of here!
Radical, yet classical, approach to the rectangle.
*high pitched* hUUUH?
Such an interesting observation to make after you find your uncle deaD?
Sewish side table - Only $9.99
Ohhh kay?
Alright then.
I don't think there's a phone here
Uh, not really hungry right now.
YEAH MY UNCLE IS DEAD!
Oh boy.
Okay.
Sooo.
So... what do I need to do?
I need to get the heck out of here... right?
Do I need to go find somebody!?
Oh.
Hi.
Pile of loose snow entered within the remains of a snowman.
The door is frozen shut, so I need...
*inhale* huh..
I need to find some way to get into the shed I guess?
But why the heck don't I just got get help?
What!? How did this happen?
There's no way I'm getting in with all this snow.
*sarcastic* I don't know, maybe it's snowing?
Maybe I'm a frickin' idiot. (true)
Let's see.
Empty glass too bad there isn't anything to drink.
Ok so if I take the glass...
I could eventually find something to put in the glass.
Yee.
Huueh.
Ayeayeaye.
Oh boy.
Can't reach it, the boards are blocking the way.
So if I can find a way in here, which I'm assuming.
If I can get into the shed I'll find something to be able to get in there... behind the boards and that should be able to help me.
But I still gotta find something to light it with.
got some snew
Packed some snow into the glass
Ok that's good
So maybe if I get...
If I put that...
OH. I can uh...
So I've got some water
Now.
So I can go and I can...
Put this on the kettle
Then I'll get some warm water.
Snow was melted in the nice warm water
So now I have warm water and I can go outside and I should be able to melt the lock.
On the shed
Yeah, that makes sense
YES!~ Melted off the ice. The door should open now.
Aah. Nobody's been in here for years.
Hammer
Lighter Fluid
And a shovel
So I might be able to use that shove to clear my car.
Let's see.
Lighter fluid...
So if I find something to light
Mmm... oh.
IT'S GETTING DARK!?
I should leave!
WELL I WANNA LEAVE
Oh god, I don't like that
OK so, maybe.
Ok so, The shovel broke but at least the snow is gone.
Run of the mill stick
The door's been bashed in... I need to pry it open.
How's the door been bashed in?!
was I just flAILING WITH THE SHOVEL
I have no idea I need to learn some self god damn control!
Ok, so maybe if I light the stick on fire...
Stick won't stay lit so...
aaaaiiiiiIII don't like that
Ok, so what I gotta do is I gotta douse the stick in lighter fluid
And then...
Just pour some on, something needs to absorb it.
Agh, So I need like a rag?
Yeugh.
Alright, you know what I think I have to go visit my uncle
That is unpleasant.
BAM!
Should pry the boards up from the edges...
Okay?
I did it!
Pieces of board...
Pried it off the wall!
Eugh...
Okay?
Huh alright.
Snip snip, there goes your finger tip!
Antipsychotics.
Aaaand... extra absorbent.
So If I take this stick...
Wrap some bandages on the stick!
Okay, we're good there.
My uncle still going to be there? *JUMPSCARE WARNING*
*MARKIPLIER SCREAM AND RAGE*
What was that all about!?
Wha- I just look rather not see that again.
Okay.
Didn't mean to go that way then!
And also why was he groaning if he's dead?
Okay so either way...
euugh.
I've got...
I've got the rag I need to go soak it. Ah sh*t..
I need to go soak it...
In the lighter fluid in the back of the shed
And then I should be able to light it on fire...
And then burn the whole god damn house down because I don't wanna be here anymore
and everything is horrible ;-;
Also, where did the snowman bits goooo?
The snowman bits are gooone.
That's not good!
That's not good at all! ;~:
Alright made a torch...
Alright so I should be able to go down here
And see!
Ah good!
A plastic broomstick it's been broken in half.
Label reads Christmas decorations
Full of odds and ends
Ah, there we go crowbar!
Ok.
I got a crowbar! *proud mark*
So now I can pry open my car door and get the fudge out of here?
maybe
Finally... I can get in my car...
What's going on!? My keys are missing!
OOOOOH NOOOO.
I have to find my keys...
Well where am I gonna find that!?
Mysteriously in my uncles place?
Why is the loading screen all weird and slow now?
Oh I don- I don't like that!
OH UNCLE!
Oh...
Why is it like that now?!
OH. UNCLES GONE!
*sarcastic* OH BOY!
Oh no...
Ah boy.
Ah boy my uncle ain't dere no more.
MA UNCLE AIN'T THERE.
It can only mean...
ma uncle
Ain't so dead
Maybe this was all just a practical joke and my uncle is just a funny funny guy! (lolno)
Let's see... where would my keys be?
I have no idea.
I mean they wouldn't be in the...
They wouldn't be in like
*MARKIPLIER SCREAM AND RAGE*
i saW THAT!
Hoo boy!
HOO BOOY!
I saw that!
Oh and the...
The paintings gotten worse
Is there anything under here that I should know about?
Maybe I should take this with me?
Yee...
Okay you know what, I'm just gonna get out of here!
Probably for the best.
My uncle is very weird.
I can't stop shaking...
*sarcastic* Maybe because it's cold? Maybe because your about to die?
Oh boy. *car starting sounds*
I'm not gonna get out of here! ;-;
HEY!
HI.
Oh! That's the end of it.
Oh okay????
I guess... am I dead?
Is dead what I am?
I think I might be dead.
Oh boy!
Alrighty then.
That was... that was not so bad!
That was pretty good for being a short horror game.
It did create a lot of ambiance,
I'm just like kind of like,
Ah, the ending was a bit anti-climatic!
I was hoping for something a bit more substantial than that, but still!
Pretty good!
Had me on the edge of my seat for quite a bit there that was not bad I just wished there was a bit more to it than that.
I reminded me of uh...
Of uh.
Kind of script welders style of making these pixelated point and click adventure games, but still!
Very good.
So, to the developer, I'd like to see a bit more to this
I bet there could have been a lot more, uh made out of these and maybe there was some secrets I didn't find.
But I'm pretty sure I got them all, so.
Let me know what you guys think down in the comments below, and thank you everybody so much for watching, and always,
I will see you... In the next video.
Bye-bye! ᶘ ᵒᴥᵒᶅ